Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel just
revealed that Mobius and the TVA from Loki
season 2 will be a big part of Deadpool 3 and is
paying off a huge deep cut storyline that they're
adapting from the comics like something you never
expected that they would actually do but that
we at fans have been asking for for a long time
we got a bunch more details and Easter eggs for
what the actual story of the movie is going to be
with Wolverine so we'll break it all down because
Deadpool is going to be messing up the timelines
so much more we just have to pray that Deadpool
will help him get one step closer to getting that
jet ski if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos of course I'll
be doing a bunch of Deadpool 3 videos in the next
year Ryan Reynolds actually just posted a new
Deadpool 3 video this is him talking about the
movie he says that Deadpool 3 is the only thing he's
going to be working on that's literally what he
means like he's not going to be working on other
movies while he's working on Deadpool 3. he will
continue to be Deadpool in the future of the MCU
like obviously this leads directly into Avengers
5 King Dynasty in Avengers 6 Secret Wars But like
after that he will continue to to play Deadpool
inside the MCU they will continue to make Deadpool
movies like Deadpool 3 isn't the last Deadpool
Solo movie but the big thing here obviously is
that Owen Wilson's Mobius is supposed to be one of
the main characters in Deadpool 3 with Wolverine
we already know that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is
going to be one of the biggest characters if not
the biggest character next to Deadpool we know
the movie is going to be set inside the MCU we
know it's going to be R-rated and we know it's
going to be the original versions of Deadpool and
Wolverine from the fox Marvel movies I think the
fact that Mobius and the TVA from the MCU being
a core part of the story tells us a lot about how
they're going to explain how all this works like
the timelines are so confusing but now that joke
from the first Deadpool movie makes so much more
sense given the context of what they're doing in
Deadpool 3 messing with the timelines mcavoyer
Stewart these timelines are so confusing and it
sounds like they're going to be doing a version
of Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe storyline
but it'll be him messing with the timelines so
much that he winds up killing the Fox Marvel
Universe his own University comes from so it seems
like they're actually doing the thing like that
was the big joke in the fandom the last couple of
years wouldn't it be amazing if they did Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe but they're never gonna
do that what if they did Deadpool kills the fox
Marvel Universe it's almost like Ryan Reynolds
and the writers were like challenge accepted so
the events of Deadpool 3 are supposed to take
place after the events of Loki season 2. like
Loki season 2 episodes are gonna happen next
summer Deadpool 3 won't come out till November
2024 even though technically the TVA exists
outside of the main timeline like outside of
all the timelines now because of what's happening
with the Kane Multiverse War what that means is
that they're relatively unaffected by things like
snaps like if anybody gets an Infinity Gauntlet
in one of these timelines and snaps it this TVA
won't be affected by it but there is meant to be
one TVA for the entire Multiverse and whichever
version of Kang winds up controlling the TVA at
any given moment is the one who's winning the
Kang Multiverse War so like at the end of Loki
season 1 when he comes back and he sees this new
version of of King it means this king is currently
winning and he's changed the timeline again so
that everybody else inside the TVA is like the
new rebooted version in the new timeline that's
why the only people who remember the original
timeline heading into Loki season 2 is Loki
himself Sylvie who escaped as well as king
and ren Slayer who also escaped the TVA itself
kind of exists in a pocket Dimension outside of
the timelines so the king can protect it from a
bunch of the minor changes that he has the TVA
orchestrating across whatever timelines he wants
them to orchestrate but Kang himself if he wants
to can change the timeline internally inside the
TVA itches that he's using his technology to make
it feel like time does not exist inside the TBA
like time does not pass where we get to the plot
of Deadpool 3 in Wolverine is that originally
the fox Marvel movies they exist in a different
Universe kind of like the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
movies in the Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man
movies there's some cases where they treat
alternate timelines like alternate universes
that's basically when they completely Branch out
into another version of Kang Rises up that's when
they become fully alternate universes but what
Deadpool did in the Deadpool 2 post credit scenes
taking Cable's time travel device and messing
with his own timeline hopping across a couple
different universes pruning variants of himself
is what gets him on Kang in the tva's watch list
the Lord works in mysterious ways don't
I a good day that was probably a bad idea
so this kind of recontextualizes what Deadpool
was doing in the Deadpool 2 post credit scene and
I think the idea is that after that let's post
credit scene he just continued messing with the
timelines changing major events jumping across
universes creating more Nexus events and that's
how Deadpool 3 pays off their version of adapting
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe but it's him
killing the fox Marvel Universe by killing his
timeline by messing it up so badly which also
flows with the theme of Marvel Phase 6 heading
to Secret Wars Avengers King Dynasty because like
they teased during Doctor Strange Multiverse of
Madness they're doing the time Runs Out storyline
where slowly universes are being destroyed through
different means either through the king Multiverse
War variants of King destroying each other's
universes or yet people like doctor strange people
like Scarlet Witch messing up things so badly
in the Multiverse and people like Deadpool doing
the same thing so Deadpool kills the fox Marvel
Universe and I think that the way they explain
this actually makes a lot of sense and because
Mobius is supposed to be a main character during
the movie he takes the lead on that in Deadpool
3 is more of a Deadpool and Wolverine versus the
TVA Mobius and Kang kind of movie but because of
what Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman teased like
I did a video decoding what they were saying
when they put the music over their voices when
they were trying to reveal the plot you see them
fighting each other there's a bunch of jokes about
Deadpool versus Wolverine there'll be a little
bit of that at the beginning of Deadpool 3 like
Deadpool versus Wolverine because both of them
heal so fast the big joke is that it's kind of
like the Unstoppable Force versus the immovable
object like if both of them heal so fast then
who's going to win that fight like who will drop
first but after they have a couple funny moments
fighting each other just healing all the damage
over and over and over they team up and then the
same thing happens with Mobius and the TVA like
Mobius tries to stop Deadpool from messing with
the timelines but eventually Mobius starts working
with Deadpool and Wolverine and they try to stop
some bigger problem technically Kang is supposed
to be the overarching villain in all these
scenarios the movie's supposed to take place after
the end of Loki season 2 and I've already done a
Loki season 2 2 trailer video from d23 so we'll
add a link for that in the description below and
at the end of this but that season is supposed to
begin with Loki explaining everything to this new
version of Mobius Hunter B15 about what happened
finding a version of Sylvie again remember the
whole joke was Sylvie is that she hides inside
apocalypse events because Kang and the TVA can't
track her there and she's hiding inside a 1970s
McDonald's implying that something really terrible
is going to be happening to McDonald's in the
1970s here but through that season Loki tries to
explain what's going on with Kang in how he is
this true villain orchestrating everything and
then they try to stop that version of Kang but I
think because this is taking place so far before
Avengers 5 King Dynasty it's implied that they're
not totally successful like Kane continues to be
a threat but I think the idea is that they gain a
measure of control over the TVA but while they're
trying to figure out what to do about Kang the
Conqueror you have all these regular Nexus events
that are very dangerous that they also have to
deal with like just because we found out what's
happening with Kang doesn't mean that other people
aren't trying to mess with the timelines we gotta
a bunch of trailer footage finding out who some
of those threats are for instance is a version
of zaniac that they're doing from the comics so we
think after the events of Loki season 2 like just
the next big thing that they have to deal with
is Deadpool messing with the timelines so you
have to imagine in deadpool with Wolverine kind
of doing a cannonball into the pool that is the
timeline Deadpool's whole thing is that however
big or dangerous a villain or a threat is like
King the Conqueror or infinite variants of Kang
is that usually his response is to do something
so unpredictable so crazy and destructive that
it winds up throwing them for a complete Loop
so that is Deadpool 3 in a nutshell the fact that
it's more of a time travel story within the scope
of the TVA is where you get to the MCU connections
like they're messing with the timelines outside of
the 616 Universe jumping around the Multiverse
but that's where the TBA gets involved pulling
them towards the MCU indirectly and by the end
of the movie they'll probably wind up on the
main 616 MCU Earth so even though all these
movies lead to what happens in secret Wars
I think Deadpool 3 Fantastic Four will be more
directly connected to Avengers 5 but everybody
posts all your reactions to hearing about Mobius
and the TVA being a big part of Deadpool 3 posts
all your predictions for the plot what you think
is going to happen my black panther will kind of
forever post credit scene will post next that'll
be up on Friday be sure to enable alerts from
my channel so you don't miss that and go see the
movie as soon as possible my full breakdown Easter
eggs for the entire movie will post on Saturday
everyone click here for that post credit scene